I so after live free or die hard or die
hard 4.0 bein pg-13 the fans pushed and
they got a new rated are die hard movie
and as Linkin Park once that in the end
it doesn't even matter a good day to die
hard or die hard five four people
keeping counter than numbers right so a
good day to die hard takes place in
Russia and it deals with John McClane's
kid Jack and Jackson a little bit of
trouble Sir John McClane goes to help
him out and now we have father-son
bonding movie with die hard guns and
John McClane who's not really John
McClane it's old Bruce Willis being old
Bruce Willis I really mean that too
five minutes into this movie I was like
where's John McClane I see Bruce Willis
but where's McClane John McClane's a
character just because you have Bruce
Willis on screen does not mean John
McClane is on screen so where was he but
I give it time okay maybe he's a little
perplexed on the situation let's see
where this goes twenty minutes into the
movie I was like where is John McClane
it was depressing his [ __ ] I was
thinking back to what I know John
McClane to be he's a burnout he's a
drunk he's a good cop he's determined
he's a sarcastic bastard who will talk
[ __ ] to his last breath John McClane and
I imagine you can make the case hey John
McClane's old now he's not gonna be like
younger John McClane but that's simply a
case in point as to why this movie
should not happen we shouldn't see old
broken-down not John McClane John
McClane on screen any more than we
should see a friends reunion episode you
know the show friends there should never
be a reunion episode because friends is
all about a phase in time they are who
they're supposed to be as the show was
air no one wants to see Monica and
Chandler married for 10 years with
ten-year-old kids any more than they
want to see John McClane not be John
McClane because he's old you see my
point so looking into the plot these
Russian baddies are doing their Russian
baddie things and John McClane and his
kid are gonna stop him his kid is boring
as hell he didn't click with me he has
daddy issues with John McClane which was
annoying his [ __ ] he kept bringing that
[ __ ] up he's like you never hugged me
yeah like you were ever there for me you
shoot like a GI Joe you never bought me
a GI Joe when I was a kid he didn't say
that but I'm just saying it got about
that annoying like shut up dude we get
it you have daddy issues you're doing
CIA spy [ __ ] do that Bruce Willis and
this guy who plays his kid shitty
chemistry on screen at least Lucy in the
last movie was cool and that brings up a
point on the last movie
or die hard I'm telling you a good day
to die hard makes live free or die hard
or die hard 4.0 look like die hard with
a vengeance I'm serious if you ever
griped about live free or die hard watch
this movie and you'll be like Oh live
free or die hards just not that bad at
all in fact it's a legit die hard movie
I think that's why this movie was made I
think fans were like this doesn't feel
like a die hard movies pg-13 come on VIN
studio was like alright make a cliched
shitty action movie call it a die hard
movie and then the fans will look back
on live free or die hard is that one
that's actually pretty awesome yeah good
day to die hard does have cool action in
that over-the-top kind of way like the
first chase in this movie last like 15
solid minutes and you swear to god god
mode is on these people get in these
cars they wirelessly link their phone to
the radio they type in the supersonic
code from Sonic the Hedgehog - dad dad
I'm tired they're just going down the
road hitting cars cars are just flying
turning into debris midair it's absurd I
mean it is entertaining I would be lying
if I said I was not entertained while it
was happening in that really mindless
action kind of way it goes on for a
while you're like okay alright let's get
to a plot also the villain who is the
villain in this movie every diehard
movie had a villain a definitive villain
where you're like that guy is going up
against McClane that guy's going up
against McClane all the villains and all
the movies do stand out in my mind this
one just Russian baddies doing Russian
baddie things and we'll never remember
the villain in this movie ever and
although I'm really bitching about the
fact that this didn't feel like a die
hard movie it was a shitty die hard
movie and John McClane was nowhere on
screen ever that's not what makes the
movie terrible what makes the movie
terrible is the fact that it's just it's
nonsense sad guys are doing bad guy
things and big actions happening that
doesn't make any sense and then bad guys
need to be stopped so that's what we're
here to do if someone held a gun to my
head was like recite the plot of a good
day to die hard I'd be like pull the
trigger I can just don't want to waste
anyone's time you're free to waste a
bullet though so given the fun action
sequences that I was like I am mindless
fun I will say a good day to die hard
had fun action but you're not gonna
remember in t-minus 10 minutes yep
already forgot don't see this as a die
hard movie see it for what it is a
shitty movie directed by the guy who
directed Max Payne in the remake of The
Omen and written by the guy who wrote
x-men origins Wolverine that's what this
is so what do you guys think I'm curious
I don't know if you
seen this movie yet I don't know if
you're going to do you think diehard can
be salvaged or you think they should
just cut it off right now I'm like nope
it had its run it's done whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more